okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p
here's an interesting little voicemail
that i got take a listen to this david
pakman your complete idiot we live in a
fantasy world I live in Southern
California and you need to finish
between illegal immigrants and
immigrants and there's a lot of crime in
my neighborhood from illegal immigrants
oh yeah so you're so far left you're
your complete idiot living in a fantasy
world and comes gonna win again and then
what's gonna happen to you all your
theories are down the toilet right
listen if Trump gets reelected it'll be
very good for the show it'll be bad for
the country but it will be good for the
show I've spoken about this before I
still don't want him to win but it will
be okay if Trump wins the show we'll be
better off than if you lose this to be
quite honest as far as there's lots of
illegal immigrants and I don't
distinguish I do distinguish between
legal and illegal immigrants but what I
have made abundantly clear is that
illegal immigrants commit crimes at a
lower rate than legal immigrants and at
a lower rate than us-born native-born
individuals and it makes sense if you
know you're in the country illegally you
know that if you come to the attention
of police you risk deportation you are
incentivized to stay off the radar of
police okay we've talked about that
period that that's really I can't even
think of what else to say okay today's
show almost didn't happen we were 10
minutes from having to cancel today's
show I will tell you what happened on
the bonus show we had what we call our
biannual tech disaster day sort of but
it was actually a much bigger picture
than that involving utility companies
and much more get access to the bonus
show instantly either by becoming a
member at join pakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
I look forward truly to telling you the
story of what happened today on today's
bonus show in mere minutes